how did you know that because the sound
of the bar wasn't moving oh
um
hello hello okay one two No it should be
better both of our bars there we go
hello
make sure it's not coming from the
camera
uh let me turn it up a little bit
testing one two one two three four five
six seven eight all right we're louder
now
this is very intense
what is this the the noise this is like
when you put the headphones on you just
forget about everything else yeah all
right let's not talk about that that's
testing one two
well we got the sound right there we go
so
we played basketball yeah and we uh it
was fun it was a little high I took an
edible oh you took an edible it wasn't
even just smoking High yeah it was
pretty fun it was it was like oh look
we're just doing it and it's just like
what are we doing we're moving our
bodies in these patterns and shapes and
we were like which pattern is the best
and where should I go yeah and then the
other people are
don't know what patterns they're running
yeah you you're following your ball
handling has gotten a lot better thanks
and like driving in yeah I've been
driving in more
using more power yeah I've been having
more confidence so maybe that affects it
and I drive in
and also like
yeah I feel like
I'm finishing because it's like I'm used
to closing it out and
getting what I want done and seeing what
I want happen in reality this seems like
a deeper thing than just basketball yeah
yeah
um no you bought this thing off Amazon I
was talking to somebody they don't think
Amazon is gonna be the future what do
you think
um I mean a lot of people hate it it
doesn't seem like it's going to last
long yeah like it's got a lot of fans
it's cool to not like it it's it's yeah
it doesn't have fans but it's just so
good at what it does
right yeah but as soon as there's
another thing that's an alternative
we're gonna be like let's do that and
they have like a better story
and uh Jeff Bezos is no longer the CEO
right hmm
I don't know it doesn't matter really
does it it's just a big machine it's
just a title he still gets money a lot
of money somehow from us yeah he likes
to
he just got a divorce too that's
terrible
why I don't know
um via Amazon I I did my shopping on
Amazon too
I mean it's convenient
so Ridge what do you think about the
whole
comedy
like do you think it's like fun comedy
or is it cringe is it ever cringe
when you're at a show and it's like oh
everyone's trying so hard to be funny
it's like not funny at all
um I guess so it goes in waves right
yeah like sometimes and it depends on
what your emotions are too it's like how
you if you're feeling good about
yourself you're more likely to look at
it positively I think so lately I've
been like I really like the writing and
Performing part but then there's a lot
of like other stuff that's annoying
yeah like
[ __ ] women
well I haven't got to that part yet oh
you're waiting I'm not okay
you're waiting like it's a choice I
don't know I mean by [ __ ] women I
mean socializing and
yeah I mean socializing but then yeah I
don't know I guess you have to be
confident to socialize I don't know
what do you what do you think
I think uh you're a part of a scene and
it's great that you're doing comedy but
you're also human and you crave
tribes and we might as well harness the
power of our tribalism for good and use
comedy the comedy scene
and the friends that we make to help the
comedy like it doesn't have to be like
weakness oh you need friends you're just
in comedy for friends it can also be a
motivation like oh I'm gonna go see my
friends so let me go do a set yeah so I
think it's good to
[ __ ] people
yeah it's it's a necessity of Life yeah
to keep the best the connection is
great for us and connection and sex is
like the ultimate form of connection
yeah it is I haven't had too many
connections
recently but I mean that's by choice
maybe
um
it just happened did I hear somebody
laughing probably
They're laughing at your life uh I have
I'm interested in Johannes where did you
where'd you grow up
I was born in New Jersey I moved to
Seattle when I was seven I moved to
Atlanta for college for four years and I
moved back to Seattle after living in
Chattanooga then I did comedy for five
years in Seattle yeah oh okay so you did
it your first five years were in Seattle
yeah how was that it was stupendous
good right yeah okay stupefying so that
was before the pandemic yeah so that was
like
2010 2012 to 2017 or 18.
that's such a different time right what
iPhone was out
I don't know
like the Obama was President Obama was
President so you realize we've only had
let's see in my lifetime I can only
remember three presidents right
Bush Obama Trump oh and then Biden I
guess that's four but I mean I don't
remember Bush at all yeah only a handful
of presidents you're only going to see a
couple more and then you're gonna die
oh my goodness
I mean you only get seven decades so
seven decades decades yeah salmon oh
if they do eight years a piece
it's interesting we have less presidents
than Super Bowls but it's long enough to
live a life and [ __ ] it up and wish it
was shorter and wish it was longer
there's no use thinking about the number
yeah
it's a more emotional feel yeah I have a
quote that says it's all about the
journey right like it the in the you
have to enjoy it I don't know no matter
what a great quote Yeah it's all about
the journey I don't know I don't know
and something about that so then you try
to like you have to try and enjoy it
right like you can't so rich down on
yourself all the time what are you doing
with your life what am I doing yeah uh
I'm doing comedy all the time and then I
just got a new job too
so I started that it's my first job that
was not through nepotism
or off a farm
and and it's boring
oh I enjoy it you don't have to it's
cool I don't know everyone hates their
job I don't hate it I don't know um
I
enjoy working for non-family because you
can just go home and you don't have to
bring work home with you you don't have
to go home and talk about it and you can
just forget about it like all right you
clock out and you're done do you think
that sometimes it's good to talk about
it
work yeah
you need an outlet and soon you're not
going to have it I guess so that's cool
if you like your job
you seems so we're bored with what I'm
saying well I already heard this you
already said this during Catan oh this
is true what uh what jobs have you had
jobs a lot of jobs yeah that was a sushi
chef
you said Sushi I don't really Sushi want
to put too much effort Sushi
um sushi chef I was a burger master I
was a sandwich there was the burger
Master Burger and burger master in
Seattle oh it's a yeah it's a chain so
what do you think about jobs do you
think that uh maybe
like people have to work too much and
they can't do comedy as much
yeah but yeah I mean I could see that if
it gets in the way just if it takes
opportunities away from Comedy that
would be a problem
but I'm not in that situation yet you
found a way to make it work yeah but
like as soon as it does yeah then it's
probably annoying
but
do your I do my job and then the rest of
it is comedy so then it's you know
I don't have I don't just fart around
all day
yeah you're busy
what do you do in your free time I see
that's the thing it's like I have a lot
of free time and I feel like I just use
it to lay around and rest up and then
whatever energy I have left I use for
comedy and it's like is it making the
comedy better because I'm having more
concentrated effort instead of like
spreading it out yeah or am I just being
lazy but yeah I rest a lot what do you
feel I sleep as much as I never have an
alarm clock I just wake up whenever I
feel like it
and what's that normally like
uh depends like today I woke up at five
a.m oh my goodness
I woke up at noon wow that doesn't seem
healthy
well I don't I don't think that's true I
think it's fine I think it's good uh to
switch it up because like
I sleep when I'm tired
and I don't need to have a certain
schedule oh that's cool so just like
whenever you get sleepy you just sleep
yeah
what so what if you stay you stay awake
for like 20 hours and then you sleep so
maybe you actually have more time awake
[Music]
that's not good I want to rest
I don't want to like just stay up all
the time and do low quality work for a
longer period of time maybe I'm getting
higher quality
effort
because I sleep more yeah but I try not
to think about it too much I just do
whatever my body whatever you feel like
yeah yeah
it's probably a better way
uh the job I have really wears me out so
I've been sleeping like great lately
yeah that's good good sleep when you're
in like not working that hard and you
sleep it's just like you don't really
feel like you slept and you just don't
feel like you're awake but if you're
like out and then you're back up again
then it's like it's way better I feel
that I like the physical part of it yeah
um but are you worried that like going
too much into your physical will take
you out of the mental and maybe you'll
just become a physical being instead of
a mental being
uh I maybe but me personally once I get
the physical out I can be more mental if
I don't get that out I don't feel like
I've accomplished anything but some
people get really into the physical and
they like get really buff yeah and then
they forget to do anything mental and
then they're just like this piece of
beautiful meat they're just like a
statue just like a bronze which is great
for now but it's not gonna last anything
you say is just gonna be destroyed by
time
but at least with the mental stuff it's
lasting yeah yeah are you trying to
learn anything new right now
I'm trying to learn how to talk to a
dumb [ __ ] redneck
how's it going what do I even talk about
a cold Bud Light and jeans that fit just
right oh tell me a pickup truck yeah oh
I'm using my pickup truck
I wish that's my goal to be successful
enough to be able to buy a nice black
pickup truck what are you gonna pick up
with it just drive around in it why
don't you drive around in something
that's optimal for driving around in
like a Corvette or like a Ferrari oh I
just like to move [ __ ] sometimes
honestly you get an 18 wheeler then
uh that doesn't get a U-Haul just no I
mean just get a U-Haul yeah put a vet in
there that manly enough just here yeah I
can move a family of four that's manly
for like under a hundred dollars yeah do
you ever see the videos of people just
like renting U-Hauls and then destroying
them yeah because they don't know how to
drive a big truck
um but yeah like I mean I have a
sprinter van and I see pickup trucks and
I'm like I'm bigger than you that's true
yeah and it's like you're acting so
manly but my van is like super
utilitarian and it's big so I don't know
like what is it that people get out of
having a big car
I have a big car and it's a pain in the
ass yeah it's hard to park places and it
takes a lot of gas mileage yeah I don't
know it's probably just my upbringing
that's just a lot of the cool people
where they had trucks
but my family never did we never had
that
um do you back to the buff people did
you have anybody in your high school who
was like
just like normal size and then they got
out of high school and then their whole
life was just getting buff yeah I had a
person like that I was like I was like
not that good of an athlete either and
his whole identity is now lifting I know
that's the thing is you never have to
really test it you just have to look
good yeah yeah yeah
I'd like that because you don't lift
again unless your body built a
bodybuilder then you're basically an
Instagram model there's no difference oh
yeah between you and someone just that
has a beautiful ass yeah and you can
make it all up too yeah
with like filters and stuff
yeah and then you just select for beauty
instead of utility
definitely uh
unlicensed apps on your license will be
disabled
hello
these people are saying yeah
um any Farmers out there
why I was I like I care what are you
gonna talk about with them farming I I
grew up on a farm okay
and so what do you think about identity
what do you think about not farming
what do you think about people that
don't Farm do you think that that they
don't Farm just like most people yeah
don't you think like we can't all be
Farmers not anymore no yeah because I
always have to actually do something
after we eat yeah back in the day like
that was the main job which is
collecting food yeah to survive and just
build a society on farming you gotta
have some culture do you think we're
going back to that well
I think that they want us to work hard
even though we have the technology to
not work as much I have to work as much
yeah so they're just getting all that
money and keeping it to themselves by
making us work I think that's part of
college too they want to get you in debt
and but they want you to have a good job
so then you feel I mean it's not like
they planned it out that way we'll get
them with college and they'll be in debt
and they'll have to work for us they're
like oh look if we if we like [ __ ] these
students over and take as much money
from them as possible then this it works
out this way and then the system won't
it's everyone just being selfish and
greedy and it just all it doesn't need
like a master planner it's just
everyone's just in it for themselves and
then you create this horrible horrible
thing that's how I feel like like people
say there's this conspiracy yeah I don't
it's not a conspiracy it's just everyone
working together the same way being
selfish like you said there's like no
master planner behind the scenes there
doesn't have to be no no Illuminati it
could just happen naturally and that's
like that's we are powerful like it's us
that's in control and that's we're doing
it and as a group we can decide no let's
do this this way and then that can
change the world but we're taught and
told that no you have no power don't
follow who cares just go work just enjoy
your personal life and don't try to like
make any larger changes and then we
forget that we it's all about us if we
don't like this system then we can
change it yeah
yeah that's definitely true yeah they're
just it's just they're not the same
thing all the time
nobody stands up I don't know what the
answer is do you want to ever do like
violence violence yeah all the time
really
that's scary yeah but like I think do
you you're getting a punching bag
installed in your house
um do you think that's too much for a
punching bag uh
because it was installed too but it's
installed that's the thing and you know
it's going to be installed right yeah
and if it's not you can be like hey you
didn't install this right and you like
it's safety net yeah it depends on your
if your situation if you don't like
doing that stuff then don't do it well I
just want to do it right yeah if you
like just want it to fall off if you
don't want it to fall off or break
anything that's the way and you have the
resources for it yeah I mean it's good
to spend money yeah me personally I
would just figure it out how to do it
but that's me that's like what I like to
do I don't think you like building I do
like building I built the whole van oh
yeah I hung that [ __ ] up I built all
this [ __ ] yeah so you do like building
yeah but not punching bags I don't know
how to get I looked at your roof and I
was like I don't know how to get to the
studs yeah I don't know what's I have a
stud finder oh you do yeah you have a
stud finder yeah oh
but I mean what am I gonna put in wood
screws and screw it in I don't know you
would need longer legs probably yeah
what what other tools do you have
I have a
socket wrenches a socket set yeah isn't
that crazy that that's like the best way
to screw things in is like with the
hexagon and you turn them because like
with the screwdriver it's like before
yeah it doesn't it doesn't hold well
yeah because rounds strip it yeah most
mostly they use Star Bits now for screws
yeah which is a lot better yeah growing
up we never had star yeah we had the
Phillips yeah yeah they round off Stars
isn't that crazy that they found out
like this is a perfect shape to not yeah
but it's still not perfect but it's
better
what's perfect nothing
well they have the socket wrenches which
I think is way better than most because
you're dealing with the whole head oh
yeah that was the CL the round ones yeah
and then the socket wrenches they have a
little circles so that the corners
you're not touching the corners oh right
on the edges yeah so then it won't strip
it off yeah the worst thing is to use a
wrong size wrench yeah then then your
screen or like a flathead and it slides
up and down and you can't twist oh yeah
flat heads are the worst they're sliding
back and forth yeah I don't know why
they don't just pick the same one and do
it that was this somebody came up with
that idea they're just like a slice here
and then this will go in here and it'll
go
it's like the laziest flatheads are the
laziest yeah it's like [ __ ] an Asian
woman
sideways vagina
uh have you [ __ ] an Asian woman yeah
yeah I'm Asian it's easy for me
it's easy for me yeah I look like some
someone they're familiar with that
they've probably already [ __ ] before
that's what you said people are afraid
of what they don't
something that doesn't look familiar
yeah
so uh what did you what have you built
with your own hands
um I also did a van like you did too
yeah but you didn't actually do it you
quit I I would no I've finished it but
then I was I didn't like it living in it
I don't know coming from the country and
then sleeping in the city that scared me
but you were all right with it you never
had any problems yeah these are my
people I grew up in the city I trust the
city I'm comfortable in this city the
city is my my environment I'm like a
turtle in the water it sounds like a
dark night at Sidious mind Gotham City
yeah and you're like oh my God these
trains are so fast they're so loud
they're all bumping into [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's just like so you're missing Trump
you never had people yeah wait you never
had people try to break into your van no
not really never no huh I that's what I
was afraid of I just because you hate
people that's why you live in the
country I don't hate people I'm just
afraid of people I don't understand
people
okay well you just gotta not be racist
and it'll be fine I'm working on it
I mean I think racism is fine if you're
just like oh this guy's sort of like
staring I don't like how these people
look
it's just you can't do anything horrible
about it I think we should allow people
to be like I don't like the way they
smell I'm sorry it's just the way I am
but I want them to have economic
equality and maybe they can have faith
but I think like to focus on like the
nitty-gritter like the emotional side of
racism is the wrong thing I think we
should focus on economic racism
yeah definitely that's doesn't seem it's
not fair at all yeah doing that if
you're just looking at that oh
um definitely
do you think this camera looks good or
do you think I should move it more
towards my side
I think it looks fine I don't think it's
any big deal right I don't want you to
get too much favorite favoritism because
it looks like you got oh more camera
it's close I don't know
looks about the same what what are the
comments like
are those real glasses yeah huh
those are just slick if you have
anything dirty you can put it in bed and
not get everything all what that doesn't
even make expect Hans to understand okay
I don't know what he's talking about
maybe he's talking about you shouldn't
eat in bed
will grow in your bed yeah
so what is it that you think that would
be like your ideal trajectory in comedy
um get better uh it might heal get good
get good get good [ __ ] I was just
talking to Brian about it seems like
consistency matters a lot Brian weak
selfie puffy puffy yeah because he's
like gaining weight
uh let's not talk about his weight
uh what do you what's a good what what
is good trajectory what do you say
you're more I would say do
open mics for two years start getting
booked on little shows in three to five
years and start doing bigger shows and
opening up for people on the three to
five year stage
and then
um
but you just move to a bigger city or
stay or like Austin which is like has a
lot of top-tier comedians here and learn
from them and absorb from five
to eight years and from nine to ten
years is when you just start [ __ ]
slamming your dick in
just pounding that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] I see you have to the
most important parts is to keep doing it
too yeah
and uh
just discovering yourself and what you
want to say and who you are and I think
the art of like talking in front of an
audience that's what I always come back
to it's like I love being able to get
the mic and be in an auditorium and have
everyone in school listening to me and
just being like uh you guys are poopy
buttholes and
I think your farts or whatever women are
not good at driving yeah I mean that's
like that Joy of it that I always come
back to is like just saying some crazy
[ __ ] in front of like a bunch of people
yeah just stuff that not everyone's
allowed to get away with but we are
because
they're like labels I guess being like
what you hate public speakers do like I
hate people with that get attention for
no reason like flight attendants like
when you're boarding a plane everybody
listen up but this is how we're gonna do
it and then like just wasting people's
time with no nothing nothing important
yeah so like pretending to sound like
that and then getting everyone in the
mode where they're like oh [ __ ] this is
just we just gotta pay attention it's
like saying the n-word or something yeah
that's oh you're yeah you're comparing
it to Comedy it's just like hey I got
all your things I'm gonna sound like
that I'm gonna make you think that's
what's going on so that your defense is
down and then I'm gonna slide in some
crazy [ __ ] that you know like it's funny
to say in front of a bunch of people
because it's like transgressive or like
like if everyone is thinking that then
it's funny because if you find that you
know because we have so much power if
you have a village and you're like okay
everyone we're gonna start drinking pee
and make it sound like an official thing
if you say it in the right way yeah you
can get people they know it's a joke and
you play around with it so it's like
sound serious yeah enough for them to
think it's funny yeah
there's this when you first start
sometimes people just say shocking
things to be shocking I feel like but
then you figure out the way to say it
what was that it was my job
do it again I can't I get I build up a
crack and then I crack and then I have
to wait how often can you do that
probably like once every 10 minutes oh
you got the light on oh my god oh no
[Music]
um
how many there's so many comedians in
Austin there's probably like 300 no
100 yeah there's a lot right
and then there's it's crazy the amount
of people
yeah I mean it's like a [ __ ]
scene do you think whenever like you
gotta nurture it back in the day before
like before now I mean I guess there's
less people in the world I'll go back to
that you think it was easier to be a
comedian like
I listened to Jeff Foxworthy he talked
about how he came up and stuff and he's
like yeah dude I have the first year
like quit my I definitely think it's
easier now yeah because of the
camaraderie
back in the day you would have like 10
people in your scene now it's like 100
200 and you can encourage each other and
you can find friends and be social okay
back in the day it's just like
you know Road gigs and [ __ ] getting
to know Old Road hacks not people your
age which I think is good and bad I
think it's good to get that wisdom from
the older generation but I think it's
more important to have people your own
age to push yourself in that think like
you and encourage you okay yeah that
makes sense but the only thing is they
had more stage time they had way more
stage time and bigger bigger crowds and
more showman like shows nowadays it's
like Open Mic so it's like good and bad
but I think overall the social aspect of
it now makes it way easier to stay in
the game
okay not as many people just quit yeah I
see that makes sense because he he was
saying how he did his first year and
he's like I made only twelve thousand
dollars my first year I was like that's
crazy I paid a thousand my first year
yeah like it's not the same but it's
like now it's like you're talking you're
doing the dance and this is the format
it's like basketball it's like back in
the day basketball was a smaller thing
and now it's huge oh that's true and
there's no uh anyone can do it too like
with comedy and you can go YouTube you
don't have to go through like certain
channels but not anyone can do it it's
really emotionally punishing oh yeah
it's just nothing to you because you
decided that this is how you're gonna I
know when I first started I was like
this is crazy because I never thought
about myself or what I cared about or
who I am or anything like that and then
it's like what do you want to say like
what are you trying to tell me and it's
like I don't want to look at myself like
that but you have to it's like yeah well
you probably got into it because you
love people and if you love people you
gotta love yourself because you're a
person too rich
you're not a cow
would from being a cow to a person yeah
you're a hybrid you're the closest to a
cow that we can get yeah uh isn't it
crazy cows they're so dumb yeah they but
they're so powerful they're powerful
they are they pull they can pull plows
and stuff you gotta be dumb if you're
that powerful if not you'll be dangerous
yeah if you're like a nerd you know how
volatile nerds are emotionally because
they're always in their heads if a
strong cow was like that like [ __ ] you
and they start like destroying the barn
and stepping on the chickens I just
picture a jack nerd just like typing
code he's like it's very aggressively
yeah he's destroying the world he's like
everyone's getting child porn at their
laptop
send it out
yeah but like cows you can keep them in
with the simplest like electric fence
and they can never figure out
well I would be kept in by an electric
fence but we aren't
yeah we are have you been to a jail oh
if you there was if you were in an
electric fence what would you do start
digging Oh you mean like an action fan
that's
oh and you were naked I don't like this
argument this is true but they have
electric fences are hard man you got to
go cows more credit
I feel like
it takes a lot more Force to keep a
human inside than a cow yeah because
humans are smart and they'll figure out
ways to get around it yeah so like if
you put a cow in a pasture and you put a
human in there
who would get out quicker
with electricity
um I would say the cow's never getting
out
and eventually
the electricity will run out but what
situation would the cow get out quicker
none if there was like a snake or like a
freaked out and it just ran it just
destroyed the fence it just yeah we just
break down the whole fence yeah if it if
it just got scared right off the bat and
just ran yeah what else could it do it
could dig if it's not really how's it
gonna Pig yeah even if it could the
tunnel I'd have to make would be huge
a human can dig that's why there's no
there's they call mule drug meals not
[ __ ] not drugs drug cows oh an
interesting thing about Farmers is
there's conspiracy that they're all gay
no not gay well maybe
um
maybe Gay you heard it from Ridge
Farmers may be gay I think they're more
into bestiality but there's basically
masturbation it's not a big deal
bestiality yeah
okay
well I mean what if you weren't gonna
get a disease like if you were horny
would you rather jerk off or would you
rather feel a nice warm vagina
yeah yeah I mean I mean it's not like
you care about the pig you're just like
using it no but you probably do care
about the Pig more than nothing well if
the pig isn't traumatized if it's like a
rape
I don't think they probably do you think
they get Trump like every time it sees
you it just starts running away it's
like I gotta get out of here yeah it
feels so good but I don't want it oh I
never thought about how anyways do you
think like
a a cow that gets or a sheep that gets
[ __ ] by a person it's like oh my God
they're like playing the game on a whole
nother level they're like like feel love
and companionship and spiritual they
actually and they [ __ ] a sheep and
they're like this sheep is just [ __ ]
me like a sheep he's so bad at [ __ ]
some of that God [ __ ]
oh yeah exactly why is bestiality
illegal it's ridiculous if they want it
if they come to you you have to do it
three times to them and if they run away
then it's right but if they come to you
then it's not right yeah uh normally
animal animals run away from you
but it's like you show them love you
feed them you keep them alive yeah uh
they start doing like [ __ ] and
licking their [ __ ] and doing all the
things that the tick tockers do and
they're like
just sexually their mind is blown do you
ever see uh do you ever read the book
Animal Farm yeah that's my favorite book
it just sounds like that's where we're
going to where the pigs just turn into
animals you mean humans oh can we spoil
it spoil alert to Animal Farm no one's
reading that stupid book that boring us
uh come on it's a short book
check it out Amazon links below sort of
blah blah you don't like it oh I mean
it's like [ __ ] everyone has to read
it so it's like become a crochet yeah I
mean I signed a lot in school I didn't I
didn't I bet when it first came out I
was like oh my God it's like the Matrix
like I never saw the end coming yeah to
the end uh they can't tell the
difference between the pigs and the
humans I know so but what's the moral of
that story is just to stay under the
humans because the if you try to make a
better Society then you're just gonna
end up like the humans anyway yeah
humans anyways so just don't try just
live in the world that you live in and
don't make it better because
so you're saying the person in charge
didn't it it was about him failing as a
leader well it's just him just trying to
preserve the status quo let's just keep
things the same don't try to do things
different because that always turns into
the pigs acting like humans which is the
same thing we have right I remember the
I love the the horse he just kept going
out every day and working and then he
just worked more and more
and then he died
that's you like that you like just being
a [ __ ] a robot I don't know it works
it was inspiring he says like he just
didn't care what's going on so I like
that to a degree because I think people
are tools and we got to do something we
not just meant to stand behind a case
and just be beautiful and looked at
we're meant to do something we're meant
to build something so build things if
you're not working towards something
then you're not really utilizing who you
are yeah that's true we're becoming
empty
we need to [ __ ] do something like
everyone's like oh I'm just perfect the
way I am but who you are is someone that
is a tool that can do something so if
you're not doing anything
you're not you're not a person you're
just just living yeah so I was trying to
do something try to find purpose right
yeah it's hard
so what do you think about the uh
the sex in Austin the sex in Austin yeah
yeah there's really pretty girls here in
Austin I think I think
um yeah they're very pretty young and
pretty what is their personality like
uh their personality is uh uh the ones I
have met
have been crazy
um sounds sexist you think all women are
hysterical
like hysterical hysterical means they're
funny right
yeah I guess so but not in a good way
not in a good way I don't know manic I
don't know if
no they yeah I feel like girls in Texas
and Austin are like either like they're
using their beauty to try to get ahead
or they're like
uh
or they're just like good just keeping
their head down and trying to do their
best there's a lot of influencers here I
feel like yeah yeah it's like the people
hanging out at the Vulcan but yeah there
is a lot of influencers I I mean this is
just the first time I've ever lived in a
city so like I've never been around this
many people before
so I feel overwhelmed sometimes by just
how much Beauty there is so then I just
don't do anything yeah a lot better than
your cows
I know that girl looks like Bessie Lou
that's a nice heifer here she got good
utter on her
that was such a fake laugh I appreciate
what you were doing okay thank you
God damn that girl is not related to me
and she has all her teeth yeah I think
that there's very smart people too
there's
um I feel like there is a tension a
little bit of uh snappiness
to it yeah I don't think women here are
like totally open they're a little
guarded and defended
I wonder if that's just the time we're
in right now yeah definitely I think
that's part of it that's what they're
taught to be right now I mean everyone's
anxious everyone's sort of fighting each
other everyone's very adamant about what
side they are and it's hard to come
together and it's not like everything's
about politics but once you practice
yelling at people and just like
disagreeing with someone vehemently it
just you start looking at people that
way as objects of argument yeah
I feel like right now is the biggest
time between like to two if you're on
two different sides like they used to be
able to get along better and you could
have a relationship with them
yeah but like almost now it's like you
can't even try because what do you think
is the cause of that
just the just the just the extremeness
of
people's opinions right
but like there's people in the middle
right
uh I think that we're diverging or like
either this is the right answer or this
but we can't do both and we got to
figure it out yeah and I think we're
very much disagreeing and I think people
are more passionate about it than
they've ever been been because they're
more informed yeah I think that's a part
of it I think also like people don't
have any power they aren't able to
change the world they're in like we grew
up like how many businesses do we
friends of ours own how many stores like
how come everything on that street is uh
owned by someone older and not in our
generation and it's like we don't have
any power or control over where we live
and then we just get mad about it but we
can't we'd never do anything about it it
just keeps happening like the crazy
stuff yeah yeah we don't have any power
I think it's economic I think if we have
we don't have money and we're just like
what do we do we got to do something and
if we had more money flowing then I
don't think it would be a big deal I
think if money flows and power flows and
we're able to influence the world we
live in but since we can't we're just
like well if I don't have any say in
this then I'll just say the most vile
stupid [ __ ] and whatever comes easiest
because it doesn't matter why would I
torture myself to have the right answer
when it doesn't matter so because you
can't answer broken you can't actually
do anything because you don't actually
have them and it's a lot of work
yeah and it's not just one person it
takes
a lot of people yeah I feel like these
are cliches we're talking about anyways
I think uh yeah we're fighting and we're
angry and we're just like we don't we're
we're inheriting A system that is not uh
an effective system and some people
don't want to admit that it's broken
sometimes some people disagree what's
the problem and what to do about it
um but yeah we're made to be this way
we're the number one goal of making a
person is to not change what's happening
it's not to make someone who's going to
be an awesome inventor wait what do you
mean not change what happening like that
isn't going to make a huge disruption
they just want everything yeah they're
they want cubicle workers and people
that are show up on time and
sharpen their pencils and that's what we
select for that's true and then whenever
whenever you like if you have a business
and you hire people that's the people
you're looking for too right yeah you
don't want the crazy people yeah
you don't want everyone to be a CEO you
need someone to you know to the the
whatever do you ever get jealous of
people that are just like satisfied do
you think they're satisfied
with like just living life just like
having satisfied with people just like
oh sometimes I get jealous like I see
people and they have they just have
their job and they just do their stuff
and they have a family and it's like oh
I'm kind of tell us that they can just
set up or like seven I mean I think that
should be a viable option I don't think
we can live in a society where
everyone's doing something crazy like
being an average person shouldn't be a
detriment or a death sentence I think
that shouldn't be looked down on either
yeah that's ideal we want to create as
many happy people that do that I think
we just need to look at people
differently and also everyone has
something to contribute I think people
are undervalued and we devalue people
too much and we should be like hey
everyone has something to offer and let
them explore that whatever it might be
yeah I think that's important definitely
yeah because if you don't honor people
for just being people then you don't
respect yourself either because then
you're like oh I'm just a person anytime
you don't meet your stupendous
expectations and you're just a person
you're like oh well I treat people
shitty and all I am as a person it's
like the bar is too high like being a
person should be something that is
honored and treasured or else you're
gonna treat yourself horribly too
that's true you never know what people
are going through either yeah you know
like if they get mad at you you're like
I don't know maybe they had a
but Ice Cube fall under their fridge
okay that's not that big a deal you
[ __ ] honky you first world problem
nobody is I've never been out sorry for
those people never been out of the
country
what really yeah
I can tell you think I should go yeah
maybe find more examples of horrible
things happening instead of Ice Cube
falling under a refrigerator
yeah it wasn't a very good one I don't
know I just got water out of it so if
you're an [ __ ] to me just cause a ice
cream fell under a fridge I'd be like
you're like Hitler [ __ ] you this is just
the worst what what is acceptable if you
get your foot ran over by a a turtle
what the [ __ ] Ridge sorry I'm losing not
a real problem you're becoming too white
you're becoming like that basketball
player that you said was too white today
it happens to be a comedian
there's a lot of white basketball
players there today yeah that we brought
everyone who thought was a regular there
was not white
ah
Christmas is coming up
do you celebrate Christmas yeah
where do you celebrating it here here
I'm flying in on Christmas oh really
flights are cheaper yep yep yep I'm
flying it uh back here the day after
Christmas
I love Christmas just a time to feel
happy for no reason everyone please be
happy now yeah but it is you do feel it
you do feel the happiness I don't know I
do it I think if there's a reason why
there's a winter solstice holiday for
everybody there's like the darkest yeah
so like it's the time when it's needed
the most when all the all the uh you
know variables are against you in terms
of Happiness so you just gotta force it
it's like dark the most amount of time
it's cool down yeah so then they would
all be on the Western Hemisphere or
Northern Hemisphere Northern premise
here yeah because the southern
hemisphere it would be it is the hottest
time of year in December so it would be
they would do that in like July sunlight
yeah do they have the same the calendar
as well as much culture
it doesn't matter when it is it's like
oh you celebrate when the days are
darkest and coldest when the years
yeah so it's like whatever that is and
whatever do they uh they just don't have
as much land down there and yeah
yeah it's supposed to be water right
land yeah
so that's just the accident of history
or Pangea Pangea that was when
everything was connected right and then
it was shifted apart yeah I'm learning
today folks you already knew that
everyone knows that I knew that yes but
isn't that weird that nobody learned it
in school we just sort of had to get it
fed to us because of the Christian right
and trying to teach us some [ __ ] do
you think I think
um Christianity is good for rights
and like
um bringing morals it's good for setting
morals where you don't murder people and
stuff
do you feel that way for like the
Western World women generally
don't we treat women better we treat
people better
um I think uh
uh maybe maybe a little bit like one or
three percent but I think mostly it's
technology oh we're just better at
technology yeah I don't think it comes
from religion oh okay but I think it is
slightly better than Islam
but not by much like a lot of the
horrible [ __ ] that happened under
religion or is
uh most of the whole [ __ ] happens from
religion yeah I mean it's just
the easiest way to be like why should I
go there uh God told you so it's like
whatever like people could couldn't come
up with a good answer for they use
religion but really it was the people
that used religion to get people to do
the Spanish Inquisition or Crusades
that's a real problem and religion is a
tool because it's like it makes people
easy to control that's why like religion
I feel like is like
it's suspect there's so much bad history
like it fool me once shame on you like
it's been used so many times to make
people do things that were not in their
best interests that's true
you think that's happening right now in
places yeah I think like abortion is a
thing or like a war like the Evangelical
people are more easier to convince like
they're they don't like our freedoms and
they're attacking our you know like like
that kind of rhetoric is easier to get
people to do stuff with because it comes
from we say we came here for Religious
Freedom and stuff like that yeah from
was persecution in the other countries
yeah I mean it's like a metaphor like we
came here to do whatever we want even
like our illogical side we can do
whatever we want with our subconscious
even Mormonism
which I think is fine
um
but I think uh like Europe doesn't have
as many Christians in it anymore they're
more atheistic and they're doing fine
nobody's going out of murders murdering
people as much yeah so I don't think
it's super necessary but I think it's
like it was good there's a reason why
religion is in every society because it
works it works at making everyone sort
of [ __ ] chill out and find out
what were the did the Huns have a
religion
uh I don't think so oh but that's when
they kind of build a culture did they
I thought they believed that they came
back
right away so they were just Fearless
maybe not I thought there was a war I
don't know who it was the Warriors they
would uh go to battle like crazy because
they just thought they were born they
were born again but you gotta be like I
don't know about this Theory it's a lot
to risk it on I've never met anyone came
back I've been like I'm actually
whatever yeah because you never
remembered really yeah or like someone's
son is like I am the reborn person of
whatever yeah but I don't know
but yeah you could just claim to be
yeah
if you're good enough at speaking people
might believe you and maybe you believe
it yourself maybe yeah because you can
tell lies to the point where you believe
it yeah what is something that you
believe in believe in yeah I believe in
God I do yeah of course
obviously yeah I just think the chances
are like if
there isn't or isn't it's better to be
if there is right and I've I don't know
that way yeah that was a scaffolding
yeah it's a thing I have to think about
too
yeah you can focus on other things
I just like whenever I hear Kanye use
God it's like oh this is just like
you being like I don't have to be
logical you can just say whatever I can
say whatever and say God told me no you
can't do that well he's doing it is he
yeah what do you think God supports
Hitler like Kanye says no that's saying
it I don't think that's good yeah at all
whenever I hear someone be like I love
God and I I do whatever he says I don't
need anyone's approval it's like oh
you're saying you only Reserve love for
something that doesn't exist and you
have no evidence for and you don't love
anyone in the real world it's like an
excuse yeah it's like no you can't do
that yeah you still have to be you have
to be a good person yeah yeah the love
and God exists in the way we treat each
other and if you look at it that way I
think it can be helpful
but uh yeah what do you think about Elon
buying Twitter
Elon Vine Twitter yeah uh I think it's
good for free speech for what he seems
like he's doing
but were you the one who said that he's
by he's soon gonna no I had a friend he
said that Elon owns every facet of our
life
energy car energy cars now he's got
Twitter
he's gonna make the the chips yeah he
you can't have one guy owning everything
yeah we can all do it we can all help he
doesn't need to be the only one yeah
it's interesting yeah we should be more
democratic
but oh and the Wi-Fi he owns Wi-Fi
Skylink he's gonna yeah yeah he's has
his hand in a lot of different pies I
think that's called being
horizontally integrated okay you own oh
all the things yeah yeah I don't know
and he could just like be like The
Mastermind right he could just go evil
wouldn't you rather have all of us
decide like we all vote do we want these
tunnels that only carry one car at a
time or do we want a Subway we should
all decide because it affects all of us
we shouldn't just be like he's richer he
knows better than me he knows better
than five million people yeah it's like
we should all have a say and then the
people that let him do the stuff they're
like yeah he makes this money so you can
tunnel everything you've done has just
made money so really the tunnel has my
money I don't know at the tunnel but
some things right cyber truck hasn't
come out yet we're not going to Mars
anytime soon like what if you went to
the
um San Francisco's like hey I want to
build this tunnel under the ground and
they'd be like no you're like what but
you're letting Elon
like why why him why does he get to do
it yeah I mean at the end of the day
it's all about who you trust and then
like shaking hands and like convincing
people to get on board with your project
yeah it's the heat doesn't seem like a
great talker yeah but he makes sense
we're like oh this is what a smart guy
in 2022 would look like he'd be autistic
he'd be smart did you see the picture of
him shirtless on the boat he looks like
a like a boat
he looks like a boat like standing up I
don't know yeah he's got a large
cavernous torso yeah it's like a lot of
space in there how much do you think he
weighs uh 2 30. 2 30 yeah yeah he looks
heavier than that but maybe maybe you're
right maybe there's nothing in there
yeah it's just so big oh what if that's
how you find out he's like a robot they
just weigh him and they're like you
weigh 10 pounds
yeah he's like a kite you could just fly
he's just tired he's getting to Mars
he's just gonna fly
that stuff is incomprehendable to me I
can't comprehensible incomprehensible
what Elon Musk being 10 pounds or him
having a large torso going to Mars
okay it's incomprehensible to most
people it's not a thing that we do so I
shouldn't be too worried about that yeah
no no one's gonna do that doesn't make
any sense yeah I'm also fly destroyed is
uncomprehensive comprehensible
incomprehensible incomprehensible to me
also it's like we're up like whenever I
see an airplane I'm like
people in there yeah and they're just
sitting like you've sat in an airplane
before they're just saying oh boy have I
you fly all the time don't you yeah man
that's why you're gonna airplane before
that's right yeah it's not there it's
basically a bus it's like a giant bus
but then you're up there yeah isn't it
crazy that it's so reliable that it's
just like every day every day
don't get enough like rep like how
amazing they are they're good but it's
like yeah I mean that's sort of how it
works if you put like a giant like uh
engine on something that just shoots you
forward
and you have a wing
they just sort of [ __ ] it has been like
the same for like a hundred years right
I mean it changes but like it's ever
since like this 50s or 60s it's like 60s
we're like okay this is it and then it
hasn't changed yeah but they they
developed it after a bird right it's
like nature Knows Best
but then they make a platypus and it's
like yeah well nature can't go 500 miles
per hour to London no with like a 300
people on have you done that have you
been in those double decker airplanes uh
maybe I don't think so it's not as cool
as you're thinking oh really it's like
yeah you can't go anywhere yeah explore
but yeah it's cool I mean when you're in
it you can't really notice because
you're just it's the same thing it feels
like you're in a bus yeah it's like
three people here and then there's four
or three people in the Middle where you
don't even have a window seat oh oh my
that's terrible
oh if people that are claustrophobic are
like in the center they're like
yeah maybe I don't know it's just crazy
how they can stuff us all in there
but they get you usually they get you
where you're going
it's amazing I can get home from Texas
to Pennsylvania 24 hours no no no not 24
five hours yeah it's way
yeah you just fly over everything less
friction it's flying there you don't
have to roll around on the ground like
an idiot
these tires we use we use wheels for a
long time and now we're like so what's
something that you think liberals do
well
[Music]
um
they they care they care about people
uh Olympics movies like do you like
liberal movies like they're fighting
they're doing that they're
doing that
liberals
doing the right like uh they care about
people they care about people help
people they're nice you think they're
more charitable than conservative we
could probably look it up which one do
you think is more donates
more time or money to Charities I think
liberal would be more I don't know I
think conservatives are in a community
where they love each other like a small
town so maybe they do more yeah they're
all homogeneous but I feel like they do
that better where it's the small they
take care of their closer Circle better
yeah but then liberals take care of
random people random people more yeah
it's more theoretical it's not like
conservatives are like I'm gonna help
I'm an animal and I I love I'm
protecting my tribe and like eyebrows
are like I love people even animals I
love everything that has a heartbeat and
like more conservatively like my cousin
he's having trouble you help him out I
don't know
and then the Liberals are like uh let's
get some water to the third world
countries which is probably good yeah
clean water more stuff like that yeah
they're more thinking about it like a
math equation broader they're able to
think broader
yeah we think simpler what's something
that liberals do badly
so uh uh these are such questions such
questions liberals too bad they are
questions
um
I think they get more excited and mad at
you
when you don't agree with them but more
that's me coming from a more
conservative background so yeah you're
used to liberals yelling at you yeah
it's more I'm a liberal and they still
yell at me oh telling you how you know
but that's we do that on both sides is
what do you think conservatives do well
is it conservatives yeah
uh uh work I don't work really hard like
a cow yeah like a cow One Direction just
tell them go that way five years later
than all the way around the world yeah
just keep going
yeah set them up and forget him yeah I
like drones but they you know what do
you think
I think uh conservatives do like loyalty
better they're more visceral they're
more like in tune with their animal side
and they're more like complete beings in
that way and they're better at
you know like
fighting yeah loyalty would be something
yeah I think Liberals are good at
uh just
uh trying to
work it out in a large scale like with a
large plan and being like let's go there
because overall it'll help the overall
efficiency and then conservatives are
like but uh that's my Granddaddy's green
green Silo and I'm just gonna stay there
yeah
I think it's I think it's good to have
both sides but I don't think it's good
how much we're fighting
yeah because you don't want anyone to
have control of everything just like
Elon you don't want 51 to roll the 49
well I think that we are coming from a
past where we're just like take
everything we can like go west and then
we're like well we ran out of things to
invade now what do we do and some people
are like let's keep invading we got more
[ __ ] to take over and other people are
like well it was a nice run we ended up
first but let's just sort of slide back
into the shadows and be like England and
a lot of people are like no we got to be
number one and it's like I don't I don't
think we have to I don't think that it's
healthy because we're gonna destroy the
world trying to maintain our lead which
is unsustainable
that's true it's like Catan if you have
all the if you have all the pieces and
you're headed towards the Finish Line
they uh everyone gangs up on you to
bring you down
yeah to a fast lead yeah but then you
look at other places like Russia and
stuff and they're still invading people
too it's like it's it's hasn't gone away
yeah well it has to or else we're gonna
die yeah
the third or third world three will be
World War four we fought with six and
Stones right yeah that's like a quote
yeah you did a butcher no
believe in yourself do things you like
or whatever yeah I don't know I feel
like an idiot it's all good I'm having a
good time well thank you for doing the
podcast yeah thanks for having me this
was fun thanks for doing it yep have a
good night